I had the surveillance thing on my phone
I could I could flip on my phone and
look to see what was going on but I used
to do it while I was driving and so I
you know you can't text and I'm pretty
sure you can't watch the surveillance
cameras either so you've got the cameras
in so when you're not here you can
maintain well sometimes I walk around
and then I go downstairs and I play it
back and I watch myself before if
somebody Falls I
was
I think the surveillance cameras are
useless she goes and replays stupid [__]
like I fell one time in the kitchen
she'll go downstairs and like watch me
fall over and over again
prison you're a huge imprisoned did you
know that in prison
Reed has a stalker I've ever seen her
like eight letters seriously he's coming
out for 26 years he would like to take
me for coffee
yeah I've gotten a guy who wants to buy
my shoes because he has a foot fetish
marriage proposals but I'm already
married so I mean unfortunately I have
to say no sorry go down the bathroom
I'll come by have a quick bite to eat
I'll go downstairs should I come with no
don't come into your bathroom
gotta check something out first before I
go to the bathroom I'm dying to find out
what they've got
wow Lisa Lisa
yes yes three seconds please
seriously are you kidding me what is
this
it's ice cream it's empty
so this one's just packed with froze and
pasta what the [__] are they
oh my God just gelato that's it
sorbet in the freezer yeah we have to
freeze is that your little machine
I love it
I'm so excited that you're into sorbets
it's fantastic
your moonshine yeah where is it over
here
we're gonna make an ice cream at this
squad and it's gonna be so good watching
all Sears thank you
[Music]
Jesus Christ how long has that been
brewing in there well it's got a date on
them I date label everything because you
taught me yeah are you drinking that
name no no I don't drink I don't even
drink that and I drink oh Jesus are you
gonna put that into the Justice yeah so
one Switzer yeah it's gonna be so good
it's gonna be so good bloody hell this
is how we're gonna do it
when my moonshine is done I'm gonna give
a shot to Pat and we're gonna wait two
days if nothing happens to him like
death or serious illness
Lisa will then take it and work it into
a gelato because
I don't think I can legally give anybody
moonshine I don't want to go to jail
no I was gonna say again
Rosary is very disorganized why are you
in the kitchen Ma you should be out on
the floor because I'm trying to help out
no no no no you gotta help out on the
floor and she's not a leader everybody
is running around burning the candle
both ends
Bella Luna should be on the map and it's
just not and we need something different
if we had to close I would be very
disappointed because we work so hard to
make the stream happen
and it would just kind of kill me
it really worked
[Music]
Bella Luna
hello welcome Chef Ramsay how are you
Tracy thank you oh oh nice to see is
this your place no I am the manager here
Rosario scolo Ryan and her two sons head
chef okay grace Mauricio the Sun so
mother and son mother run the place do
you normally greet customers before they
even get out the car no you're special
I'm special you absolutely special I'm
happy to be here you smell good
um on a scale of one to ten how bad are
they minus chill oh [__] you're very
stubborn Rosaria cuddles Jaffe you know
if a customer sends a plate back she'll
defend the Sun instead of saying the
customer is always right wow that makes
me insane are the locals biting no no no
no no and this place should be banging
we have to do things I run a 50 Shades
of Gray Bingo on a Thursday night is
that again 50 Shades of Gray Bingo it's
adult Bingo adult Bingo handcuffs
involved no no well they could be if you
want it I mean why would you no God no
she's mad just arrived we just try and
think of anything that will create a
buzz a stir okay your hair looks great
by the way all right turn around and
it's lovely
can we get inside please come it's an
honor thank you for the briefing by the
way oh appreciate it thank you
all right
um oh Jesus is it Christmas
wow yeah what's with all the Christmas
decorations
um we are in the middle of July right
it's Christmas in July
hi oh hello hello
I'm Italian that's what we do nice to
meet you let's go inside shall we have a
little chat
excellent
okay uh first of all um let's go back to
the beginning how long have you open uh
three years three years okay good and uh
what kind of background do you have I
don't have experience of owning my own
restaurant neither did my son but we all
have the passion for food and since I'm
Franco went to school and he wanted to
become a chef you know this was our
dream so he has Russian experience
uh well when he finished school he did
an internship in Manhattan and then
after that we just jumped in here so I
won't say
he had an internship to ownership yes no
come on so we are yes what about the big
bit in between the things called
experience didn't have any but you had a
vision we had a vision
so how's the food I think it's more
authentic than than other places around
here we make everything fresh we don't
use anything Frozen that's crazy
I have one freezer and this is the way I
want it to be I want to bring out fresh
Italian food but why wouldn't Easton
Embrace that why wouldn't they support
you I don't know I think they're used to
one thing and like if they're used to
frozen food and you give them fresh
authentic they would not appreciate it
so you're saying to be more upset with
fresh as opposed to Frozen yeah the food
is not the problem here it's probably
more of the community really don't know
about fresh authentic Italian food
thank you
he lost my very carefully just stop
staring at me because he's you know he
just stands there and stares
having a little dish first to put this
oil in please oh yeah
hey Mark okay so stop staring at him put
your creep in the mouth man
it's a little dish
oh
teaspoon of oil let me put the oil on um
I'm not quite sure it wasn't back there
wow
oh my gosh it's so thin it's just liquid
is that normally that runny that the
hummus I've been told it depends on the
garbanzo beans ready we're gonna stop
blaming our [__] beans with hummus
there's times where the hummus will be
extremely thin or there's times where
the hummus will be overly thick yeah
it's not Bean's fault it's the chefs I
feel like I'm always apologizing for the
food now we're done I'm done with that
okay but I'm not a chef
control
I didn't do the advertiser I did it I
said it a lot of oil it's tradition to
put a good amount of oil on hummus so
for Chef Ramsay not to like it is a
shocker to me I should have made it
there's a disgusting busing station that
looks Dreadful there has to be a much
better place to put dirty dishes than
that
I'm out it's weird how you just drop all
those dirties there yeah
yeah that's where our dishes go why not
just walk five feet and put the dirty
place inside the plate wash I don't know
how difficult would it be to walk
straight into the kitchen and put them
in there not hard at all Chef Ramsay is
right but every time I try to open my
mouth every time I have a suggestion I
basically get told to shut up
you're welcome
it's ready okay I'm coming
you put the Zed on and what's supposed
to see the zoo for Xena kind of a design
looks like someone's puked up on my
plate oh come on does that look
appetizing to you yeah
it doesn't look too appetizing it
doesn't look appetizing at all no
okay thank you no problem
uh
that looks like the inside of a diaper I
mean it's so bad
jeez he said she's a father means look
like someone threw up yeah okay tell him
enjoy your meal and
um I'm done there darling one mouthful
too much
one thing I can confirm it tastes the
way it looked Dreadful nope not a winner
crazy
I don't agree with Chef Ramsay about
some of the items that's a first I will
defend my food to Chef Ramsay because I
know how healthy and delicious it is
when did the salmon arrive
couldn't tell you honestly you couldn't
tell me I couldn't tell you oh my gosh
I've seen that salmon in there for a
while I don't believe that either I'm
just saying I don't believe that either
that's okay okay
why'd you go in denial when they're
telling you the truth and they're
they're in the engine because I'm the
one that orders
I don't cook it but I order it
last time you ordered salmon probably
two weeks ago
why are you shaking your head because
it's been in there longer than a month
Trevor that is [__] [__] do you
think customers locally do you think
they should leave their home to come
into your restaurant
and pay for frozen food that they could
cook better at home I think our food's
good
standing by my food I think our food's
so
what part of store-bought frozen food do
you think is good I think our food's
good help me to understand what part you
think is good I think it's good I mean I
don't understand what you're asking me
okay so out of all the dishes that I had
the veal piccata that's old that you
agree to I do the the lasagna this
microwave that's Stone Cold not even
microwaved properly and there's salmon
with the paint I'm asking you very
politely what part of your menu do you
think is good I think our food's good
but you're not stupid I'm not stupid so
meatballs Frozen sauce watery lasagna
they can't even [__] reheat it
properly and then why are you blowing
smoke up your own ass telling yourself
in a deluded way that your food's good
or if I missed the trick and I haven't
ordered something that you said I should
be eating I think our food's good who's
telling you it's good the customer
they're not coming that's why you're in
Denton you put your funds into this
place
nothing come on then man up I will say
this we have never had a customer Andy
will but I have very had very few
customers ever actually complain to my
face okay uh you know I'm not interested
about the customers that blow smoke that
we asked currently I'm interested
customers that aren't coming any longer
and truthfully most customers don't like
to complain to your face they just don't
come back they vote with a fee
I don't think you've got any idea how
this business is functioning I do
understand how the business responsible
you don't know what's on your menu you
don't know how it's written your chefs
disagree with you I mean I I've never
seen so many people so far apart and the
proof in the tasty because it felt just
all over the shop
you are way out your depth the food
Bland boring dated and when a head cook
can't even operate a [__] microwave
that scares the [__] out of me but the
owner said your food's good so continue
kissing their ass
wow my food's good
my food's good yeah my food's good
well that wasn't pleasant
surprised I didn't walk out of this
place two years ago
[Music]
Trump's being a little [__] prick
don't cry
it hurts my feelings you know
you cry I'll cry
that was brutal
that was a little too rough
outside
[Music]
that was very unpleasant
I don't even have ever felt like this
before ever
in my life
this is horrible